[Music]
um Shaz is going full fascist though you
know the guy that was just in the the
last video this guy this guy that was in
the last video that I was shown you he
just some he just some citizen in that
school board in that school district
just went and spoke his mind spoke his
truth and I appreciate him speaking his
truth in the way that he spoke it I know
the audience does that's why I played
him twice but shaz's fascist ass wants
to mute
him hey Shaz are you for freedom of
speech are you scared are you scared of
of other people's
ideas this is why I welcome descent
folks this [__] right here this is why I
welcome
desent I welcome it because I'm able to
defend my opinions I'm able to change my
opinions I'm able to do it I've done it
in my life hell I came from rule white
racist
Missouri I've got so many racist jokes I
could tell you that are stored away in
my first 20 some years of adult of of my
life got a lot of them oh
man got a lot of
them some of them pretty damn
funny but they're racists as
[__] they're gross they're vile
do you know how many of those jokes I
tell now not
one hey Shaz let let me give you a good
idea about how to change your [__]
mind and how people change their [__]
minds I've told this story
before it's one of the things that
really
transformed my world
viiew and what I mean by that
what I mean by it transformed my
worldview is that I use the worldview
that I thought I had and I applied it in
the areas where I was
delusional they'd convinced me of
lies
right because I know you're a [__]
homophobe oh you're a big gay hater Shez
that's why you want to mute this guy
because this guy's talking sense right
and the more this guy talks sense the
worse it is for the cause to oppress the
rights of other people in this
country so let me give you a little
insight on how a human being changes
because I've done it and I'm not ashamed
to tell the story a lot of people
wouldn't tell the story especially this
day and AG you're like oh my God I would
never admit never
admit that gay people offended me they
did offend me they don't
now because I used my worldview to think
about
it and I thought about it and the more I
thought about
it the more I thought well my [__] my
everything I've been taught about this
thing is the exact opposite of my
worldview my worldview has always been
freedom and liberty I don't know I don't
know I don't know if I I was born a
liberal if you think a certain way there
a way raised my mom my mom raised me to
be a
liberal you
know so I don't know I don't know if
that's if that's
um if that's what it
is and I don't know what it is maybe
science tell us one day but Shaz let me
tell you a little
story I was just out of high school and
I went to
Chicago to visit a friend of mine he was
at a school in
Chicago
it's a very liberal
area and we went to a party one night
when I was staying up there it was at a
friend of his house they were renting a
house we went there there was a cute
girl that I kind of you know was sweet
on the last couple days so I thought oh
y'all we'll go to the party you know
what I mean and we get to the
party and there's a couple of my friends
friends there from school and they're
gay they were they're
gay
and they were sitting in the kitchen
everyone's having fun right it's a party
people are drinking having fun you know
being underage some of them of age
drinking doing drugs getting
drunk stuff the college kids
do and the two two of the gay guys that
were in the house there were in the
kitchen and one was sitting on the other
one's lap at the table
they weren't they weren't being
sexual they weren't kissing they weren't
really hugging he literally was just
sitting on his lap but they were gay and
they were
together and my little snowflake ass at
the
time because I thought that should be
offensive oh man I want to mute this guy
you
know and I didn't I didn't make a big
scene of it Chez I didn't make a big
scene of it what I what I did was though
is I I
did the wrong thing in the in that
moment I went to my friend I was like oh
man I can't take this I'm I'm and really
what I should have said is I'm such a
snowflake and I it's a me problem
because I'm letting them affect me even
though they're not doing anything to me
they're not asking me to sit on their
lap they're not asking me to be
gay they're not asking me to do anything
I don't want to
do and everyone knew why I was leaving
right again I didn't make a big scene
out of
it I didn't have to for them to know why
I was
leaving and we left the
party and I've I thought about this for
a long time and for a long long time I
was really ashamed of
it cuz when I reflected on it I was like
God I'm such a [__] what a [__]
[__] that I couldn't sit in the house
and have a fun time I mean hell I was
trying to get
laid and I let I let some dude sit on
some other dude's lap get in my way
because I knew they were G I've seen
guys sit on each other's laps
before hell I've sat on another dude's
La a heterosexual
dude and I let that get in the way it
was a me problem see it was a me problem
so I had to reflect on that right and I
used my worldview that I had to reflect
on it chz that's what I
did and I decided that I was [__]
wrong I was dead wrong and for a long
time I was [__] ashamed of it
oh man I was really [__] ashamed of
it and I'm not ashamed of it I shouldn't
be ashamed of it you know
why because I thought about it I thought
about it I know I was wrong I know I was
the one being the [__] bigot in that
moment now I
know and I know going forward what I can
do not to do do that stupid [__]
again cuz I let my brain guide me I let
my thoughts and my worldview guide
me and I'm willing to tell that story
right here on the air I've told it
several times before you go back you can
listen to the story oh it changed Tony's
lying nope it's real that's a real
[__]
story
and do I wish that it wasn't part of my
experience hell to the
no hell to the
no I am so so [__]
glad that I was able to use my to use my
inner strength and my worldview and my
thoughts and that process of
understanding why I was wrong and why it
was a me problem not a them
problem
I'm
grateful for that experience and the
reason why I'm grateful for that
experience it's because it it is what
leads me to talk to you about these
issues every [__]
day it's your experience that's all you
got
right that's all it
is that's all this [__] experiment
is life us walking
around in flesh
suits is just
experiences and if you're not listening
when other people talk about their
experiences if you're not
listening and then you don't filter it
through a proper thought
process I mean I could go read the
letters from Bin Laden right I can go
read
them I would put them through a filter
and a worldview that would probably spit
out what I'm spitting out today I don't
have to go read it to know that it's
propaganda I know where it's coming from
I know why it's why it's coming from
that that
institution I know why it's coming from
that
worldview I don't need to read it to
know that it's
propaganda Nazi Germany had all kinds of
great propaganda that sounded oh
fantastic
fantastic I mean mine C man that's a
that's a hell of a book I mean it talks
about his struggle right that's what
mine cof stands for my
struggle Hitler's struggle he's a victim
oh he's a [__]
victim what a [__]
victim in that moment in that college
party that I was
at I felt my struggle oh it's my
struggle that that I struggled with
these two gay guys being in the in the
same house as me oh I'm such a
victim how stupid of me right what a
[__] ignorant
bastard but if I can change my worldview
or if I can use my worldview to change
my ways to change my thinking to get me
in a position where I'm like that really
wasn't my struggle it wasn't my struggle
at
all that wasn't my
struggle what I'm not the [__] victim
here I'm the one that had a problem not
them they didn't have a problem hell
they were having
fun [__] they loved each other for all I
knew and what the [__] is it any of my
business anyways
so stop being a stop being [__]
victims Shard
Army and the and the new recruits of The
Shard
Army who are
justifying jihadist
propaganda stop thinking you're the V
you're not the [__] victims you're
not you're not the [__] victims
nope
stop thinking you are because you're not
and and
Chez stop being a fascist mute this guy
mute this guy oh you scared of this
guy's ideas who his scary ideas oh my
God his scary ideas oh man for freedom
and liberty oh man you're scared of him
calling you a Nazi like you are okay
mute this guy [__]
he